l'inde est sur le pied de guerre pour le
lancement d'une campagne massive de
vaccination
un véritable plan de bataille organisé
depuis des mois le premier ministre
indien aux personnes en a donné le coup
d'envoi ce samedi dans quelques minutes
l'un d'eux lancera la plus grande
campagne de vaccination au monde
je félicite tous les citoyens indiens à
cette occasion vacciner 300 millions de
personnes soit l'équivalent de la
population américaine en six mois
un défi colossal qui a fait l'objet
d'une répétition générale dans le pays
cent cinquante mille personnel soignant
ont ainsi fait et refait les bons gestes
avant le lancement de la campagne
sans oublier des livraisons fictive aux
quatre coins du pays afin que tout soit
prêt pour le jour j
l'ampleur de la distribution des vaccins
et bien sûr énorme
elle est de 600 millions de doses dans
36 région il faut donc prévoir le
transport la logistique de la chaîne du
froid
c'est à dire le stockage les seringues
supplémentaires l'élimination des
déchets biomédicaux et ses 3000 centres
de vaccination 29 1000 points de
stockage des chambres froides et près de
86 milles réfrigérateurs et congélateurs
mobilisés pour la conservation des
vaccins un plan logistique colossal dans
un pays où les infrastructures restent
vétustes surtout dans les régions les
plus reculées
autre frein à cette campagne le
scepticisme d'une partie de la
population
deux vaccins ont été autorisés en
urgence celui d'astrazeneca ainsi qu'un
vaccin indien le coc vaccine dont
certains experts pointent du doigt le
manque de données et des essais biaisé
mais les autorités de leur côté se
veulent rassurantes
ce n'est pas mal car anglais concernant
les deux vaccins qui ont été autorisés
en urgence en inde
nous n'avons absolument aucun doute
quant à leur sécurité autre défi pour le
sous-continent combattre l'inégalité
d'accès aux vaccins à la fois physique
dans les régions rurales les plus
enclavées et sociale dans un pays où le
système de castes reste la norme et les
différences culturelles très marqué
l'enjeu est de taille avec plus de 10
millions de cas pour plus de cent
cinquante mille décès l'inde est le
deuxième pays le plus touché au monde
derrière les etats unis